so now I'm going to increase the
difficulty mode on you Bart because we
all know that you're kind of an
emotional
robot I thought you going to give me a
compliment I want to ask you a question
that that will perhaps make you look
good what was an emotional moment with
Gio where you were like can't
[Music]
compute welcome back to careful boys we
are afraid of everybody today we're
talking about a part two from the part
one where we asked what was a moment
when you fell for your significant other
yet to go myself bomu and Joseph go so
let's go Bart and then we'll go Joe and
then I will go as the host I will go
last wow so organized um for me I think
that moment was in
[Music]
20 it's [__] up dude no no we want to
hear after we got the tattoo he's been
so mean to me guys what cuz he knows
he's in now he knows in and now he get
we can't fire him Coast he can coast and
he knows like our 10 don't call me now
[__] he's a wild boy firing him would
be the best because then people are like
oh who do you have that tattoo with he
goes the guy that fired
me that's so funny can you finish your
[__]
story what is this '90s
bully uh I think it was two yeah it was
2010 it's probably one of the most broke
times of my life cuz I just graduated uh
College didn't quite know what I was
going to do just yet me and Joe were
still figuring out if we wanted to
pursue JK at all cuz um we were doing JK
doing College also working part-time so
it's one of those things where like
social media wasn't even a thing you
don't have these [__]
multi-millionaire ticktockers or
anything like that it was uh very like
watching this world getting built uh
from the ground up and uh during that
time I'm like [__] what do I do like I
did just spend four slash five years
getting my undergrad do I continue onto
medical school or do I do this thing
that I love but it makes [__] zero
money I think like at that time our
checks were maybe like 1,000 bucks every
like 3 or 4 months or something so it's
literally enough to like we shoot for 6
months and maybe we could buy a new lens
or a new camera it was like and then
maybe buy some granola bars for some
people that shoot with with us and like
that's it it was like zero money but we
really really enjoyed doing it cuz we
would do it um every weekend we would
drive down to the OC to film we would
like pull all nighters to edit like it
was just like a really really fun thing
for us and we can see the community
building cuz we started getting booked
for shows already so we see momentum and
movement and growth just not in the form
of like monetary
benefit and I think during that time and
I I remember I was in um I moved in with
and she was living with a bunch of like
roommates her age and I remember uh
sitting on in the kitchen I was just
sitting on the counter and then like she
was like standing next to the oven and I
was like [__] I don't know what I should
do like I'm like I need money I don't
want to rely on my parents I [__]
hate them
and oh I think I was also still
part-time military still and I was like
[__] I still got to do the reserves and
[__] I'm like what should I do and then
at that point uh she was like just
pursue JK I'll support you and I was
like damn what the [__] so the first one
the Sugar Mama you just made you go oh
wow yeah I was like that's [__] cuz
no one's ever done that for me and I was
like that's [__] cuz she was a Korea
woman already she was a banker and then
I was like what do you mean like I could
just keep doing this and then you'll pay
for everything she goes yeah I'll just
cover it food whatever everything that
you need you'll stay here and just keep
going until um you figure it out and
that was just such a mindblowing concept
that I was
like okay I'm going to take care of you
for the rest of my life just because she
said that so that was that that moment I
can support you too dude you want but
she was bluffing cuz you ended up having
to pay for everything yeah she played
the long game she played the long game
and she [__] it all she was bluffing
she was bluffing I'm just kidding she
was smart who would have thought yeah
dude I think that changes like a regular
boyfriend and girlfriend to more like
long term oh for sure that's a huge step
that's also a huge commitment cuz most
boyfriend and girlfriends won't really
how how long would she supporting you
after that conversation she never did
but the fact that she said that [__]
played you dude you got got no I think
it's one of those things like once
someone tells you she never did I think
once someone tells you you don't need it
anymore yeah you know like the whole
burn the ships concept it's like it's
like it's like that you're like hold
burn the ship burn the ships explain so
so burn the ships is like um people say
like never have a plan B so if you have
a plan B you will fall on Plan B so burn
the ships is like if we go attack this
[__] Island the minute we land on the
enemy's territory we burn our own ships
cuz we're going to [__] kill them and
steal their ships and and sail back so
you burn your own [__] ships we keep
our ships and then we have a fleet yeah
it's kind of a waste of so that's the
concept of burn your ships I think that
changes the relationship to more of an
actual team that's working toward a
future and investing into each other
versus like what's mine is mine and
what's yours is yours I hate that [__]
yeah I really do no cuz I I do I know
couples who are like you know well
that's his or that's hers like that's
her like this we keep the finances
separate and all that stuff but you're
not working as a team like the team part
is the cool part like that's the best
part yeah and the communication too cuz
I can see how like just with Jill saying
that I think even for me like the
expectations of of being a little more
traditional in my head of like guys just
pay for stuff and girls like run the
house and stuff and whatever then that
already goes oh wait so I don't have to
pay for everything and you'll take care
of me like that would change it for me
too for some just to say that that's why
it made me go oh [__] I better turn [__]
into overdrive if she's that down and
never have to tap into that like first
aid kit so now I'm going to increase the
difficult mode on you B because we all
know that you're kind of an emotional
robot thought I thought you were gonna
give me a compliment no no no no no no
no I want to get I want to ask you a
question I want to ask you a question
that that will perhaps make you look
good what was an emotional moment with
Gio where you were like can't
compute that's not emotional no no I
think it's like she's a writer and you
like yeah it's like it's no she I know
what it means right she's going to be
your writer and all that stuff and I
think that's tight she's just
calculating his EA do dude just like
how's how's this going to work out
logistically emotional
moment say emot um can you use it in a
sentence how about this is this
emotional cuz I don't even
know there was another Mo so my parents
are [__] from Looney Tunes right
they're not of this Earth Wy coyote
they're [__] crazy and Tweety Bird
when me and Gio uh we're
living in uh my mom has like a property
we live in the back it's like a little
Triplex and we're living in this like
garage one day out of nowhere me and J
are sleeping and we just hear [__]
rustling and [__] like a [__] tree
branches and like we just hear like all
this activity and no one would be in in
the back unless like you know so we're
like okay so it's like either one of the
roommates from the front or it's
probably my mom then you hear like Keys
jingling and [__] I'm like because my
mom will never knock on the door she if
she ask keys to she's just going to open
it so she opens the door she comes in
like hey Mom and then G's like hey like
M what's going on and then she goes
today I'm going to marry you guys and we
barely been dating for like 6 months or
whatever what this is a funny one yeah
what so like I don't think I've ever
heard this like Jill's like wait what
she was like oh don't worry we're going
to marry you guys love each other so
happy so she comes and she sits us down
you sit here you sit here and then she
like holds our hands and stuff and then
she goes okay you love her right I'm
like yeah you love him right and I'm
looking at GI like I'm so [__] sorry
my mom's [__] crazy and then and then
J just looks at me like what the [__]
going on I'm like I don't even know this
is I I've been dealing this my whole
life and then she pulls out Rings she
like says her own crazy ass [__] vows
that's like a mixture of Buddhism and
[__]
lunacy good combo yeah she puts [__]
a gold ring on me gold ring on her goes
okay now you guys are married kiss and
then we kiss and then my mom leaves and
uh the fact that Gio didn't leave me
right there and like being able to like
accept what the [__] is going on I was I
was like dude this is this is pretty
cool because I don't know who else is
going to accept [__] someone just
having the keys to your place just
entering and then just having the
craziest what the hell iest wise ideas
she'll just have them and they just
happen and that was at like 1: in the
morning or some [__] I forgot I was like
has your mom like officiated or like
ordained anybody else nope I I I
remember when that happened I think her
concern cuz she's so like conservative
right was uh Bart and Gio living
together and I think she did that to
somehow justify it in her own mind and
make peace with it cuz she's like
they're not even [__] married or like
I I think that's why she forcefully
committed the marriage cuz that was so
wild to me I wait I wasn't living with
you at the time but I was down the
street I think maybe yeah but it was so
wild to me that I was like what the [__]
and then I was and then I think like I
tied everything together and I was like
the motive sounds like she couldn't get
past her traditional ways so she had to
construct something to justify it the
fact that we're sitting here it's like
10 years later still trying to figure
out what the [__] that was about is why
it's so odd yeah pretty she's [__]
have you ever asked her about it no I
just move on there's too I wonder if she
even remembers well she's adopted me
against my will really yeah I like the
against my will like I don't want to be
adopted I want to be a she walked up and
she well so for for some reason she
thought I had she she didn't think I had
Parents I'm not surprised it don't seem
like you do yeah yeah she was just I'm
like I have a mom right and she goes I
am your new mama now you going to call
me Mama and I'm all like huh and then so
she was trying to basically tell me like
don't worry like I'm your new family and
I'm like I got tons of relatives in
California like I'm good like I got
family and she goes no no no I'm your
new mama like you could call me Mama I'm
all like that's very loving of you but
I'm like laugh way my mom works the way
my mom works is she thought I was some
orphan with no parents the way my mom
works is like
this create a
conclusion act on the conclusion and
then go oh why don't you tell me that's
that things go so when me and Gio got
married in Hawaii Gio had like the
roughest uh relationship with her dad
and they had like a a threeyear like
silent period even at the dinner table
they just pretend like didn't exist
right the like and then it took a lot
for them to rekindle everything and then
they they they uh formed a way better
relationship
after when we got married and in Hawaii
um we were going down like hugging and
crying like all of our parents and Gio
was and and was hugging her dad and
they're both crying and sobbing because
I think like now they she's a full-
grown adult she's marriage is able to
make her own decisions and then kind of
like putting all that crazy trauma and
past behind and it's a thinge where it's
like there's the people that are like at
the like
altar the doing the altar thing and
there's the audience thing my mom puts
it upon herself she gets up and then she
walks over to that Embrace that has been
like overdue for two decades be happy
come on be happy and trying to separate
the two I'm like Mom sit the [__] I
think this might even be in a vlog sit
the [__] down Mark goes and grabs her
sit the [__] down my son's good cuz she
just made a conclusion like she thought
he was sad that now like the daughter's
getting married off and then later on I
explained to her I'm like no they
haven't talked for 3 years whatever
whatever she's like why did anybody tell
me I'm like because you don't jump to
conclusions first dude bring your mom on
JK dude and the time traveling auntie I
need a hot seat I need a hot seat with
Bart's mom yeah dude she's cuckoo man
Steve's going to get to her Steve's
going to figure her out I'm I'll figure
I'll crack
it Jo takawa dude uh I feel like our
relationship has been anything
but uh predictable and traditional like
there's orders to how things happen
right but it almost feels like the way
that we got together was
like almost like we got married first
and then like a traditional traditional
but then in the beginning you know when
I visited her met like when I first met
her in the UK and all that stuff like
that was just normal like modern like
just hooking up like who who would have
thought like you know it's so long
distance right there's no intention of
that going anywhere and then we both
were in the same mindset of like I just
want to have fun like a lot of people
it's difficult to have something like
long term with because of maybe our
experiences or whatever but we just kind
of were jaded not bitter but you know
what I mean like just kind of you had a
lot of luck and love yeah yeah so it was
like but we're still human and we want
affection and we want you know all that
stuff so I think that was our mentality
going into it but along the journey I
just felt like there was nothing
stopping me from moving forward every
step of the way whether it be like
emotional or intellectual or like
through everything there was just there
was progress that didn't feel like there
was effort yeah you were an emotional
match yeah everything just balanced and
it felt easy so I think that was one
thing that was so different cuz it's
like most people have to work to court
there were differences and things that
we didn't quite get yet and like yeah we
fought like in the beginning where we're
like misunderstanding each other but I
think getting back to that Baseline and
that Comfort was um much more different
but I think the the biggest pivotal
point cuz I think like relationships to
that point can be very if you been into
a lot of relationship it can be kind of
similar where it's like yeah everyone
feels butterflies when they are
infatuated all that stuff in the
beginning right it it happens very
commonly but the pivotal point for me
where it was like marriage and the of of
of the first sh was um I think she's the
first person that actually understood me
and was able to communicate who I was to
me oh [__] so so like maybe I couldn't
articulate
my intentions or how I felt or maybe I
was um misunderstood by other people so
they told me who I was like maybe
someone told me like oh you're
unromantic or whatever right and I'm
like oh maybe I am they branded you
right so then maybe cuz I didn't know
myself very well I just took on that
definition of who I was and I was like
yeah sure but then I think um she said
there were moments where she was just
like you know you're a very romantic
person and things like that and I'm all
like huh like I've been told I was was
cold or like whatever or I'm not that
good at this and that she goes no it's
cuz they don't know guys like you and
I'm like you're exactly like my dad or
you're exactly like my brother my
brother shows love this way and I'm like
oh and then so she's like yeah people
just don't know how to take love the way
that other people give it they wanted
their they wanted their way but she goes
you got to meet in the middle she goes
it's like the whole love language book
right it's like some people give it a
certain way and then you're over here
getting mad because they're not loving
you the way that you want it to be done
or like they're not see they're
receiving love that you're giving yeah
and it's like everything is just having
empathy for both and not getting mad
that like people she's like I get it if
like you you're annoyed of the
miscommunication but she goes I don't
understand like how people react so
angrily to someone missing the mark yeah
and I was like oh [__] yeah that's
probably what happened where like I was
missing the mark and then I was getting
blamed for it so I was just like I'm
going to just give up why even try right
and then so I was like that was like
next level to me cuz I was like wo [__]
I never had someone not only understand
me but help me um connect better and
then it made me made it an open
environment where it's like all right
well how do you like to be loved and let
me try to experiment and it was the the
space between us is we have a really
like cool um it's almost like this like
free safe space to just try like doing
[__] without there's patience there
right so like it's not like um you know
she communicates how she wants something
done and then immediately if I [__] up
I'm reprimanded for it which it's
happens a lot in so many relationships
cuz whatever is going on in in them or
me or whatever like it immediately gets
into a fight cuz people get butt hurt
but in our situation I think she's
created a a a envir
and this is not even me doing it this is
all her she created that environment
where it's like it's just a cool loving
space you feel safe you can [__] up and
fail and and she'll help guide you
instead of punish you yeah and it goes
both ways cuz now it's like I'm learning
from that and it's like oh [__] this is
what a good loving healthy space is cu
she loves you yeah seriously yeah that's
what it's all about yeah but I think
that that literally was the moment of
like oh [__] I didn't even know these
kind of relationships existed and then
so um why I'd be stupid not to you know
be married with her and like keep her
forever you know yeah was there an um
same question I asked B is there like an
emotional moment like a like a Eureka um
moment that happened I mean obviously
what you just shared is very emotional
but was there like a something some kind
of argument or some some some Catalyst
no there's I don't think there's
catalysts but I do think like
it's it's a it's a um it's a collection
of tons of moments that basically
confirm every single time cuz it's like
it it can't just be one thing it's like
a a mosaic yeah like everything added up
and it's like oh this is completely
different um yeah I I I don't think
we've had one moment actually where it
was like a big kind of thing you just
built a big strong thing together I
think yeah there's so much complimentary
things everywhere that it's hard to not
appreciate it yeah what's what's your
love
language um I think it's acts of service
and quality time but like I and amount
of weapons that so far gifts weapons we
try to do all of it but I I think what's
cool about her is like if I tell her
like
um if I'm lacking somewhere or like if I
don't take the initiative to do it it's
not that I don't want to it's just I'm
not trained to express that way so just
I know it might be weird to and it might
be unromantic for you to just ask cuz I
think like sometimes people like to
surprise or whatever and then I'm like
but you're going to have to just be
literal with me and then so I think the
cool part is that she accepts that and
she goes all right so when she wants
attention she goes I need attention
right now or she'll be like yeah can you
hold me right now and it's like that's
the best thing cuz then it's I don't
have to [__] guess Nikki does that to
me too it's the best but it's so much
more easier than like why aren't you
doing it already and it's like what the
[__] [__] what the that's so mean you
know like
yeah but yeah I I think that's the cool
thing is the the ability to negotiate
and communicate yeah well you guys just
have this the matching love language
like it really is I think that's that's
the that's the other thing too is like
we don't have to try hard to be not who
we are like we already can exist and and
and be that and then there's no pressure
huh I really disagree with people who
say that relationships are so [__]
hard like to cuz to me if you got the
right match it's it's really easy and
it's convenient it's like nice that your
partner does things the like the like
matches you so well that like when you
you do something or you [__] up they
pick it up and like you're good like or
like you can you can conflict resolve
really quickly because you have the same
emotional intelligence did you have a
pivotal moment with Nikki so it was like
a catalyst so for me and Nikki it was so
yeah we got together it was hot and
heavy right
immediately I love that that's the best
we date we go on a date date hard then
the next time and and she's already like
texting her friend like hey do you want
chicken or steak at the wedding when her
friend goes how's it going right and it
was like nuts like we were just having
such a seamless date and we'd already
been friends for years right so then um
that probably helped that cuz you guys
already knew each other and who you
really were without trying to impress
each other and I already really liked
her as a person and we had a great ball
busty friendship which is I need that I
cannot be with somebody who worships me
or whatever the [__] I need ball busting
or worries if you're literal or not
thank you yeah you get you actually get
me really well it's pretty funny um some
[__]
but but um say loud but the moment for
me it was like our our second date and
we like go back to her place and like
we're not having sex we're making love
like like it was like wa it's a slow
thrust that's a crazy ass thing to it
was insane bro it was insane like it was
just like we both were it we were both
in that like that weird you had your
legs wrapped around her and stuff oh
yeah give us more details she had my she
had my legs she had my legs over my head
she had my dick on and she was dting in
my she had your
legs Steve had his [__] ankles behind
his neck dude he had a pillow under his
low back he was like let's do itang do
it mommy like make me sick dude Che and
then um no but that I mean after that
like and we fell asleep in each other's
arms and all that [__] and the next
morning I wake up and like my all the
blood on my left side's dead cuz I was
like holding this [__] all night and
stuff but I wouldn't have had it any
other way didn't want to move even like
it was just like holy [__] I had never
made love like that that's a unicorn
moment to have that so that was your
first time with her and you already knew
yeah like that was the
wow I know it's like [__] fairy T
[__] that's mainly infatuation for
most people and then it just gone I bet
it probably had something to do with you
guys knowing each other cuz it's not
it's the big prerequisite cuz the
infatuation is usually like when you or
when you meet someone fresh yeah and you
don't really know them yeah I'm not
going to say I know for sure but I don't
know how that didn't help you know what
I mean like of course it probably helped
but did she agree on this one she was
like we were making love or she was just
like I was just pounding you she's like
I was just taking your I was just taking
your pee peee yeah Steve's all like it
was so romantic and magical and then
[__] Nikki's like I needed some dick
man I haven't [__] in like six months
she like I made that dick my
[__] no
it no it it's something we always talk
about we talk about all the time and it
was just like a definitely a catalyst um
for us and then um you know after that I
remember also one of my favorite things
she ever did for for me was I was going
on a trip to see my brother graduate
from the Air Force and [__] and like on
my way leaving she gave me like this
like whole package of like things that
she had made me of like you know day one
when you're gone day two when you're
gone day three when you're gone day cuz
I was going to be gone like for Monday
to Friday and like it was like like a
she had like written me like letters and
like yeah it was like so cool and and
then she had done this really cool thing
too where um so like you know I'm big
Colts fan stuff like that so she got
like a Marvin Harrison Jersey who's like
a Colts Legend right and she's wearing
the Marvin Harrison Jersey and like
these really cool underwear and she
sends me like these sick photos that she
took and sick photos send some back did
you send her some she's like bent over
like opening her butt cheeks all the way
open and [__] you know what I
mean showing me that whole
thing oh my God and that honestly like
during I think I missed her so much that
I was just like you ski the guration
you like [__] it it's the that movie
where they're running the other
way and he's on the phone like no yeah I
was there I was there yeah yeah it was
great it was a great thing yeah you
didn't see me I was there and honestly
it just gets better with us every single
year like it really does like we're just
so close and like I call her the magic
lady cuz when we kiss it's just like
boom B bo bo bo boom like the fire man
that has nothing to do with the fact she
pays all your bills she pays for
[Laughter]
everything she us a St for dick dud
that's what she uses she she's like I'm
going to take care of you forever and
I'm like and then she actually did
it she didn't go back on her work yeah
know she didn't go back on
work I lose this
money they just sell cars like hot
cakes